des rires des performances sportives la
7e édition des olympiades de versailles
était programmée dans la ville ce
week-end au stade mob auront le concept
les valides et non valides se retrouvent
pour partager un moment de sport quand
on est face à une personne situation
handicape
on va aller vers elle en disant je vais
faire une berge donc on va aller vers
cette personne on va comprendre quel est
son type de handicap
on va s'adapter à elle pour pouvoir
l'aider et l'accompagner et pour moi
c'est les bases du vivre ensemble
le vivre ensemble c'est aller vers
l'autre comprendre l'autre écouter quels
sont ses besoins et s'adapter à l'eau
pour faire passer un moment rare
pendant cette journée les participants
ont pu notamment s'essayer à
l'équitation l'activité était organisée
par le club hippique de versailles
partenaire de l'épreuve depuis la
première édition
je crois une activité qui plaît
énormément sur ces journées des
olympiades ou les les personnes peuvent
venir découvrir et se mettre à cheval et
va découvrir les sensations que procure
la mise à cheval sereinement dans une
ambiance festive du bus beaucoup de bien
j'en fais depuis un bout de temps déjà
l'événement attiré près de 1000
participants cette année rendez vous en
juin 2017 pour une nouvelle édition des
olympiades de versailles